the guy just loved to compete has a
tremendous understanding of the game of
basketball
[Applause]
we'll go to the line I mean I love them
as a player prize to that but just
looking at them listening to it they can
find themselves in a situation where
they can line up their offseason
priorities and their front office
priorities much better than losing the
situation they had the previous season
born and raised outside North America
Nate is dousset as an assistant in the
NBA the last 18 years gotcha - another
great pass to the Andre Jordan that's
gonna be a talent to watch this year is
gonna be stuck there for quite a while
[Music]
Cain inspires to eight and underneath
and eight nine slam sit down first he'll
go on a while for eight he's at 12
points dodge hits a pretty move and then
he scoops it up and in timeout Phoenix
for the post will get out of my way
splits the double
[Music]
Basescu Dallas nacho to d20 Andre
gave mark here at his mercy it's
courteous spoke so strong guys lot of
guys played small Brunson pretty
physical himself put six on the clock
ain't and squares up here comes dockets
he's got eight make it ten now get off
to a hot start got the foul trouble but
as I don't see anybody make it that easy
eight and wet the blocky tip this is a
neat check right here